[Music]
oh my God on this Tuesday night disaster
from torrential rain in the northeastern
U.S this is nowhere near over the fears
of what's next for Vermont while parts
of Canada desperately need rain what
people are being urged to do Ukraine's
fight to join NATO the reluctance to set
a timeline what president zielinski
calls absurd and to help the alliance
will provide in the meantime the opioid
emergency cutting indigenous lives sure
how do we do something that people will
continue to Die Why governments can't
agree on how to help
and the tiny Canadian lake telling the
story of how humans have profoundly
altered planet Earth
[Music]
global national with Donna Friesen
more than 11 million Americans are still
under flood watches today after a
summer's worth of rain fell in parts of
the northeastern U.S the American
President Joe Biden calls the flooding
catastrophic and has declared a state of
emergency in Vermont the hardest hit
areas of that state have been drenched
with more than 230 millimeters of rain
in two days and that's led to more than
100 rescues as Raging flood waters shut
down roads and trap people in their
homes
good evening and thanks for joining us
there is a small break in the rain
tonight but more extreme weather is on
the way and the ground is already
saturated some dams in Vermont are
reaching capacity and people are being
told they should be ready to head to
Higher Ground at a moment's notice
Jackson prosco has our top story tonight
the rain may have stopped the water is
unrelenting
a raging torrent sweeping across parts
of Vermont New Hampshire and New York
bridges washed out and it was you know
like a six foot
sinkhole
that absorbed the road and there's a
pickup truck floating down there
two days of heavy storms delivered two
months of rain redrawing the landscape
leaving communities cut off and isolated
the river had actually jumped its bank
and went around around a few of the
houses pinching them off from the road
Vermont's Capital Montpelier remains
under threat after receiving an all-time
record amount of rain Monday a nearby
dam is nearing capacity and could send
even more water Downstream if it
overflows people will think this is over
but it's not over
because the rivers could still rise the
water has to go someplace the reservoirs
are filling up Rescuers are going door
to door looking for people Still In
Harm's Way so far they've plucked dozens
to safety we still have reports of
people trapped in flooded homes and
vehicles Vermont has long been
identified as a potential climate Refuge
a place supposedly at lower risk from
the worst impacts of global warming this
one in one thousand year Storm shows
nowhere is safe this is based on past
climate data not the present and
definitely not the future claimant so
what is a Thousand-Year storm quote
unquote will become more likely a
hundred or worse than that with more
rain forecast this week residents have
little time to assess the damage we are
not out of the woods
this is nowhere near over
a far-reaching disaster that may deliver
more misery in the days ahead
Jackson prosco Global News
in parts of Canada it's not rain but
heat and dry weather fueling and
environmental catastrophe according to
the Canadian interagency forest fire
Center more than 860 active fires are
raging across the country now over 500
of them are out of control this year
more than 9.5 million hectares of land
has burned far surpassing any other year
and it's only early July more than 300
of the fires are burning in BC dozens
sparked in the last 24 hours as Nita
garcha reports on top of the evacuations
and the alerts people are being told to
conserve water
foreign
something that could have been quite
horrific there was finally some relief
near Smithers after Wildfire came
dangerously close to the town in
Northwestern British Columbia I've never
been that close to a wildfire I feel a
high level of annoyance if I see
sprinklers watering driveways or sending
water out onto the road provincial
officials say restrictions on water
usage are likely on the way with half of
BC's 34 water basins at a level four of
five on the drought classification
system as they urge everyone to conserve
water by taking shorter showers not
watering plants during the hottest times
of day and limiting dishwasher and
washing machine use we are anticipating
continued extreme fire behavior and all
of us need to do our part to prevent the
situation from becoming any worse no
matter where we are in the province
a province-wide campfire ban excluding
the island of haidaguay is also in
effect the BC Wildfire service is
appealing for more out of Province help
it's so that we can give our BC Crews uh
the appropriate rest and reset so that
they're ready to action buyers later
into the season even with all the
resources you know how we get actual
good precipitation for a long period of
time that's what's really going to make
a big difference the balkley nachoco
regional district is also hoping for
rain I've lived in this same Community
same farm for all of my life and I
haven't seen it this dry at this time of
year ever that since I've lived here
BC's widespread drought conditions also
cause the tender dry conditions
contributing to a record Wildfire season
which has already seen more than a
million hectares burned we owe it to one
another to be very careful officials at
all levels of government are reminding
everyone of the power of their
individual actions to prevent the
situation from getting even worse
Global News
a little later we'll tell you about how
a tiny Ontario Lake holds evidence of
Humanity's impact on Earth and marks a
possible new chapter in the planet's
history
but first NATO leaders are in Lithuania
for a key Summit that could change the
course of Russia's war in Ukraine
Ukrainian President Vladimir zielinski
and his wife are there arriving for
dinner tonight along with other world
leaders he is frustrated with NATO
though in its decision to Grant
membership to Ukraine only when it says
conditions are met despite Ukraine's
demands no clear timetable has been set
for the country to enter NATO David
Aiken is traveling with Canada's prime
minister and reports on the conditions
and what help lies ahead
Ukrainian President Vladimir zielinski
was greeted like a rock star at a rally
in the Lithuanian capital of Vilnius
a few kilometers away inside the NATO
Summit leaders including prime minister
Justin Trudeau are ready to greet
zielinski as a friend but they are
cautious about welcoming his country
right now as a full NATO Ally we agree
with the open door policy of NATO and we
are in favor of Ukraine joining NATO
when conditions allow NATO allies have
different views on what conditions they
are looking for that would trigger
Ukraine's accession to Nato the most
common precondition an end to the war in
Ukraine however that might happen but
other allies have concerns about the
interoperability of Ukraine's military
with NATO militaries and still others
are concerned about the kinds of
corruption that existed in Ukraine
before the war still NATO leaders did
agree to a package of three elements to
support Ukraine now first a multi-year
assistance plan for Ukraine which
includes support for reconstruction
second a new NATO Ukraine Council where
both sides so meet is equals to discuss
the war and any future crisis third we
reaffirmed that Ukraine will become a
member of NATO
and agreed to remove the requirement for
a membership action plan removing that
action plan requirement will speed up
Ukraine's eventual access to Nato but
again only when conditions are right
this is a strong package for Ukraine and
a clear path towards its membership in
NATO this NATO Summit is also meant to
be a show of Western Unity against
Russia but there are some divisions here
divisions over Ukraine's candidacy for
example or defense spending and also
some opposition to the United States
decision to supply Ukraine with
controversial cluster Munitions but
Canada's foreign minister says the
overarching message is the alliance will
not waver when Putin invaded Ukraine he
thought he would divide us but the
reality is we are more united than ever
zielinski said it was code absurd that
Ukraine was not offered a clear time
frame for membership so Lansky will get
a chance to express his frustration
tomorrow when he takes part in a session
with all NATO leaders he is also
expected to have one-on-one meetings
with U.S President Joe Biden and with
prime minister Justin Trudeau Donna all
right David Aiken in Vilnius Lithuania
thanks
all six people on board a helicopter are
dead after it crashed near Mount Everest
the helicopter flown by a Nepalese pilot
and carrying five Mexican tourists was
on its way back from viewing the world's
highest peak Nepal's civil aviation
Authority says the helicopter lost
contact with the ground about eight
minutes after takeoff it is monsoon
season in Nepal in bad weather may have
led the pilot to change the flight path
all six bodies have been recovered and
an investigation is underway the
indigenous Community pleads for help
coming up why life expectancy is now
dramatically shorter for indigenous
albertans
indigenous communities in Alberta are
sounding an alarm the opioid crisis that
has claimed so many lives across the
country has significantly lowered life
expectancy according to Alberta Health
Services the average life expectancy for
a First Nations person in 2017 was 71
years by 2020 that number had dropped to
just under 67 one year later in 2021 it
dropped even further to just over 63
years by comparison life expectancy for
a non-indigenous person is 81. Heather
York's West explains why this happened
and what needs to change
thank you
today Buck breaker is a well-respected
leader on the sikhseca First Nation but
it wasn't always that way I've been
homeless I've lost families jobs
you know been in jail and all because of
addiction a traumatic childhood LED
breaker down a path of addiction he's
now been sober 11 years but all around
him drugs continue to claim lives I
think 2020
as a nation I remember we lost about 92
people so 92 deaths in one year that's
sort of a population of how many 8 000.
we know that over the years the
substances have become more toxic across
Alberta the opioid crisis has become so
bad the Confederacy of treaty six First
Nations declared a state of emergency
asking all levels of government for
immediate support
but on this file the provincial and
federal governments don't see eye to eye
hey
the Alberta Government has signed four
deals with First Nations communities to
build treatment facilities on their
lands the premier accusing Ottawa of
falling behind on its own responsibility
to provide indigenous care which is why
we're working in direct partnership with
First Nations to address it in response
Ottawa says Alberta is playing politics
pushing a solution with no mention of
harm reduction or safe supply for almost
20 years I've been saying you cannot
help people there's no recovery there's
no treatment model for people who are
dead still the promise of a new
treatment facility in sixtica brings
breaker hope either we do something or
or people will continue to die because
right now across the province two to
three albertans are dying from drug
poisoning every single day Heather your
ex West Global News Calgary
the Assembly of First Nations has a new
interim Chief Joanna Bernard was sworn
in today at the afn general assembly
after the organization removed former
National Chief Roseanne Archibald nearly
two weeks ago
we know the decision that was not taken
lightly
and was a result of careful
consideration by the leadership and the
respect and representatives of our
Nations
Archibald who was elected in 2021 was
voted out after an investigation into
workplace harassment complaints not all
chiefs were present for that vote
Archibald says she was targeted for
fighting corruption and demanding a
financial audit and accuses the
organization of silencing those who are
questioning her removal today Archibald
attended the assembly virtually as a
proxy for another Chief and she was
later removed from the meeting after two
terms at the microphone
allegations of forced labor ahead to
Canadian companies under investigation
for their operations in China
a gold mining Corporation and the
Canadian branch of Nike are being
investigated for possible forced labor
being used in their supply chains
these are very serious issues that have
been brought to our attention and so it
wants the investigation to identify the
veracity of those and to what extent
ottawa's corporate ethics are announced
the first of two investigations relating
to China's uyghur minority Sherry
meyerhoffer says that dynasty gold a
gold mining company has argued it does
not have control over the mine where the
alleged abuse is taking place and she
also says Nike Canada claims it no
longer has connections with the
suppliers in question there's no clear
timeline when the final report will be
released
a suspect has been charged in connection
with a stabbing on the Toronto subway
25-year-old Moses Lewin appeared in
court today on several charges including
attempted murder and aggravated assault
Witnesses say two men got into an
altercation on the train last Thursday
the victim was taken to hospital and is
expected to survive Lou and Romaine in
custody until his next court appearance
and work is underway in Toronto to fix a
problem that is tainting a brand new
attraction less than three weeks after
the city opened Love Park its
centerpiece a heart-shaped Pond has
turned green the city is blaming a
mechanical issue it says it's working to
try to address the issue Love Park
officially opened on June 23rd in
Toronto's Harbourfront
evidence on Earth next the big Discovery
deep beneath this small Canadian lake
[Music]
take a look at this volcano in Iceland
erupting just 30 kilometers from the
capital Reykjavik Monday afternoon there
was intense earthquake activity in the
area causing a 200 meter long fissure
and bursts of lava there's no imminent
danger though and no disruption to
flights but people are being told to
stay away because of potentially noxious
gases it's the third such eruption in
Iceland Southwest peninsula in three
years
you've probably never heard of this
small very deep Canadian lake but the
news about it is Big it's called
Crawford Lake and buried in the sediment
beneath it is geochemical evidence of a
new potential chapter in the earth's 4.6
billion year history the clearest and
most pronounced evidence of humankind's
influence on the planet nestled in a
secluded spot just about an hour's Drive
West of Toronto Crawford lake is at the
center of a Monumental declaration about
a new chapter in geologic time the
anthropocene epoch today after 15 years
of study a panel of scientists has
declared Crawford lake is the best place
on Earth to Mark the start of the age of
humans Jeff sample on what the little
Lake reveals and why it matters
10 minutes from Canada's busiest Highway
sits this Serene Lake which holds the
secrets of human history it's an
incredible sight Tim Patterson and his
team of geologists have spent years
studying Crawford Lake created 13 000
Years Ago by a collapsed cave the little
lake is incredibly deep reaching down 24
meters the bottom is so well protected
that it's become like a time capsule
absorbing thousands of years of History
when the geologists retrieved samples of
sediment from the lake floor they found
its layers were like the rings of a tree
each line offering Clues to its age
these layers for example formed during a
terrible drought in 1935 but by around
1950 the chemistry of the lake began to
change when essentially there was
enormous Economic Development as the
world recovered from World War II
radioactive plutonium was found in the
mud thought to be from nuclear weapons
tests thousands of kilometers away the
sediment showed effects from acid rain
and fossil fuels and some microbe
species began to disappear and now we've
changed the character of the system so
much that we're actually leaving a
geologic record of human activity
Crawford lake is unique no other body of
water on Earth is known to contain this
combination of attributes and this
little lake has now caught the world's
attention
thesis and this International Panel of
scientists announced Crawford Lake had
been chosen to Mark the start of a new
chapter in Earth's history known as the
anthropocene or the age of humans human
beings as a species are becoming the
greatest force of nature this renowned
Canadian photographer produced a
documentary on the anthropocene the
world altering event that some
scientists consider comparable to the
extinction of the dinosaurs and today
we're having a slower motion
um uh Extinction event but we are now
the equivalent of a meter impact
scientists are still debating whether
anthropocene should be considered an
official Epoch and samples from Crawford
Lake will be used as evidence it is the
first step towards the potential
ratification of anthropocene as a
geological Epoch and Crawford Lake also
offers hope in recent decades as the
world reduced nuclear weapons testing
acid rain and coal powered production
something incredible happened the lake
began to heal
Jeff Semple Global News Milton Ontario
declaring a new chapter in geologic time
is not done lightly here's a little bit
of background geological epochs are long
periods of time typically around 2
million years separated by major changes
to the planet such as the massive
exploding meteor that ended the late
Cretaceous Period and wiped out the
dinosaurs 65 million years ago since
then kind of like a calendar scientists
have classified seven geologic epochs on
Earth the most recent being the Holocene
which started at the end of the last ice
age 11 700 years ago the anthropocene
anthropo meaning human would be the
latest about 20 years ago a Nobel
prize-winning chemist Paul krutzen
popularized the idea that science should
recognize the huge impact that humans
have on Earth from species Extinction to
biodiversity loss and climate change and
search for the so-called Golden Spike of
evidence of this new Epoch 12 sites were
identified studied and debated and now
little Crawford Lake in Ontario has been
chosen as the Golden Spike the ideal
marker showing where one Epoch ends and
another begins that is global national
for this Tuesday I'm Donna Friesen
tonight's your Canada something a little
different some new additions at the
Calgary Zoo red panda parents udaya and
Linus had their second litter of cubs
twins the zoo's Nursery camera shows the
mother bonding with her babies thanks
for watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow bye-bye
[Music]
thank you